[Music]
dylan you're getting a lot of love for
the sexy bad guy i i mean a lot of
people
oh yeah how
is that i want to know because i want to
be the sexy good
guy you already got that
thank you sir tonight chris is lending
marisha hargitay a hand in the murder
investigation of benson's brother
i don't want to talk about the other
night elliot you have to take care of
yourself
but what fans really want to know is
when are benson and stabler
finally going to get romantic that's a
complicated situation
with me being a recent widower or
her having had moved on and now has a
child grown that
you know let's figure this out if
this relationship needs to go to another
place mauricio's husband was really
funny
about talking about your relationship
together well you know we
we have our sunday evening come together
session just to work out all the kids
for that week
i'm telling you i've never told this i
look forward to seeing peter almost as
much as i
i look forward to seeing marisha listen
i also have to ask you the internet had
a moment
about and about your butt and i
and it just kept coming
my i had to get a publicist number one
that's just like
yeah look it's very nice you know i am a
man of a certain age so and look if
they're talking about
you know good and then if they're
talking about your show even better
dylan was just like i'm done i'm not
gonna be
you